avait amerri l'oriental satan ne peut
louer c'est en deux jours
[Musique]
je crois pas moins fait futurs pêcheurs
et vous vous y croyez
de la campagne à la ville les jeteurs de
sorts sont partout et tous les milieux
sociaux sont concernés
n'importe qui peut être ensorcelé mêmes
n'importe quoi comme ce tracteur en 1982
aussi avait connu la route monsieur cent
chez les messieurs voilà ce qui se
passait
je lui ai acheté un tracteur hauteur
jusqu'à la ligne
j'avais fait le plein comme il faut
faire quand on est en bas la ligne caen
gp une paire d'heures
il s'est arrêté libraires je vais pas
tenir à la direction river puis livrée
ne paniquez pas et fait appel à un
guérisseur blouse blanche et plaques
professionnelles
c'est très sérieux mais attention la
prestation est payante par comment ça se
passe vous aident les inventeurs mois
pour réussir ces guérisseurs des outer
sauget numéro de siné je paye ma thé
vert pour chanter clients j'ai presque
comme on dirait au connu ça revient cher
sur les prix dans les années 1980 la
sorcellerie
ce n'est pas seulement une histoire de
campagne c'est aussi la ville alors à
qui la faute
avec l'exode rural la croyance se
déplacer géographiquement et socialement
de la campagne vers la ville
aujourd'hui près de 70 % des personnes
qui croient à la chancellerie vivent
dans les grandes agglomérations où que
vous habitiez la sorcellerie est proche
de vous
comme ici en 1985 en banlieue parisienne
où une messe noire a été organisée
par les esprits inferno par le chaos de
la vie ça tu en viens à d'où ça vient
d'où
[Musique]